hi I'm Sal Khan founder of the Khan
Academy and I'm Caroline who Flexer
founder of deaf deafness and we have a
very exciting announcement today as you
probably know Khan Academy is a
not-for-profit with a mission of a free
world-class education for anyone
anywhere and we've always viewed core to
our mission how do we how do we meet the
needs of our of our youngest learners of
kids in preschool or who might be in
kindergarten and whenever we thought
about this in the past we always look to
duck duck mousse as really the the best
company out there I'm a father of young
children and they to some degree grew up
on these apps and so it was very
exciting when Caroline and her team
reached out to us and proposed that we
join forces we're thrilled to be joining
Khan Academy duck duck moose is an indie
developer and originally we started
designing apps for our own children and
now we have 21 early learning apps and
we're we've always been a mission driven
company concerned about kids and
education and trying to make the biggest
impact and I think this is why this is
so exciting for us being part of a
larger nonprofit where we can really
make an impact on kids all around the
world and you already have an incredible
suite of 21 apps which now are going to
be free and really free not download and
then we try truly free because we want
young children all over the world to be
able to have access to this learning and
as a reminder to you the only way we're
able to do this is with philanthropic
support so if you are a big supporter of
this vision please think about donating
so as you can imagine we're all very
excited that now duck duck the duck duck
moose team is now part of the
not-for-profit Khan Academy and keep a
lookout for what's to come because these
these 21 apps are just the beginning we
have some fun plans ahead of us
absolutely